author david halberstam it's been almost
a year since the publishing of your book
The Reckoning would you change anything
or add anything to it since the events
of the past year since you finished
writing the book no I don't think so i
think that which i wrote about which is
really the japanese in east asian
challenge to american economic hegemony
american industrial cores more visible
now than ever the problems are is great
they may even be greater because in fact
one of the things that the people who
ran detroit used to say was if they
could only get the n dollar evaluation
be more equitable and was too soft they
wouldn't have no problem problem
cleaning up the japanese most of the
time line did the book the evaluation
with something like 240 n to the dollar
now it the last year it has gone down to
about 150 or 140 and in fact the
japanese continue to be very very
impressive and particularly in
manufacturing and we betrayed the
deficit with amounts so that was detroit
people like the people in Detroit said
would happen which is a girl give us a
break on the yen dollar will turn it
around turns out not to be true it's
this very serious endemic problem for
our society this is a problem of what's
wrong with ours or what's right with
their a little bit of both I think the
Japanese had a very good economic system
terribly well tuned they waste nothing
less goes in at one end and more comes
out in other it's a great distillation
system and we have after 30 40 50 years
of affluence we become careless we
picked up the number of bad habits and
while we're improving the Ford Motor
Company is a good example of an American
company that's improving we have a long
way to go and the Japanese are not a
stationary target how much of that is
good business and how much of that its
cultural I think a great deal is
culture oh I you know but in any
cultural extended into into good
business but I regard Japan is sort of
the culture of adversity and America as
is the culture of affluence in there you
know with the comparable strength
greater freedoms here greater
expectations greater carelessness Japan
you because of the nature of the poverty
of this rocky little island the lack of
natural resource you cannot waste at all
so therefore you build up a system in
which there is no wasting author David
Halberstam is our guest for the next 45
minutes as we take your phone calls and
your questions from around the country
we didn't find you to join us now as we
open up the phones with eastern central
time zone the phone number is 20 26 28
25 25 to live in the mountain or the
pacific time zone that phone numbers 20
278 3 27 27 and you can see those phone
numbers at the bottom of your screen
will start taking your calls right away
again this is the most recent book of
our guest this morning it is the
reckoning I David Halberstam it is the
third in the series of books that he
wrote which one did you like the best
what I don't know I think I an author is
it's like asking a parent which of your
children do you like that's it I'm very
proud of this week it has by the way
mercifully for who your listeners come
just come out in paperback to it is on
it's going on the paperback bestseller
list which is nice so they can buy it
now for a great deal less than the
twenty dollars or so it costs a year ago
I want to talk before we get back into
the issues in this book a little bit
about the journalism of the book why did
you choose the two companies that you
chose and why did you choose the
industry that you chose reflecting there
you are and you know something seven
years ago you know something really
quite important has happened between
America and Japan the trade imbalance
mount Japanese companies are doing
things right clearly American companies
like Chrysler and even forward with your
bankruptcy harvester with your
bankruptcy something had happened if
you're going to do this how do you
dramatize it I think you pick out an
industry let me pick out steel so
there's no consumer index television
sets would have been too small cameras
too small auto is at the heartland of
the American centrix core of this great
middle class I thought so on and here
the Japanese making better covers so I
picked auto Chrysler then okay how i
watch the Carter what do you do I think
our Chrysler was absolutely near
bankruptcy GM seemed too big to
impervious to change in fact it was in
fact to its own detriment it was because
the things that should have been
changing their three and four and five
years ago didn't get changed and now it
is more vulnerable than Ford and
Chrysler so I thought Ford was a very
good middle company I mean a great
company great names I mean Ford much of
the world a car whatever it was made was
called afford I mean it Henry Ford
brought in the American Century I mean
with the Model T in which workers could
not just be workers but they were
consumers as well so I thought Ford
would be a good company and if I did
them they were the number two company in
this country why not do Nissan as the
number two company in Japan for same
Jimmy didn't want to do for to then go
to Toyota so you had to have some
symmetry just pick up the phone and call
them there to here I started writing
letters and then you just go out and
work hard for five or six years all you
do is give up your life for five or six
years and in the end one day there's a
book it's magic what was the biggest
surprise free night in writing this I
think the degree to which we gave away
our manufacturing strength that which
had served us so well these were these
great industrial companies and they
created manufacturing the making of
products engineers as second-class
citizens I think the second thing I
think that I've begun to learn is the
importance of education and how we have
slipped in education in the basic areas
not high education and how the Japanese
have the other asian nations have used a
primacy of education as a means of
making this assault let's go ahead and
go to the phones this morning Willard
Ohio you our first caller yes all in all
ques
there are rules to corporations in jet
in Japan isn't it true that no one can
ponder on the corporation the government
really owns it they're like the be like
panda only like the owner going on forty
percent of the company and its harm the
head tapping 12 ok it doesn't the
government go to these got to take money
give Honda no I think that's an
exaggerated view of Japanese capitals
and what is true is the government
certainly is more of an advisor
confidante and guide to Japanese
companies and it takes place here I
would if I were describing Japanese
capitalism and I think it suits them
very well for the next age we're going
to I would call it state guided communal
capitalism but those are private
companies by and large I mean toyota
four engines the most successful auto
company there is still a family company
they one significant difference they
have two significant differences they
have one is that they have company-wide
unions that is to say where where we
have industry-wide unions they have a
company while using which makes it which
mitigates against a strike if you are a
worker at Toyota or Nissan a new strike
Toyota you hurt Toyota and you helped
Nissan and your own bonus is affected so
that that is a limit in right there on
what a union can do the second thing is
where we get much of our financing of a
company from our stock market from an
equity market market which demands to
the manager drive the stock up and think
short range they have a very close
relationship with their bank which allow
but it's very hard to tell where the
company ends and the bank begins its
quite incestuous it allows their
managers to think long range and that's
probably one of the things we're going
to have to change the long-range I think
we have to be more long-range nevis an
idea of comparison of the receptiveness
of Nissan to your kind of project
although some people were receptive at
all hey we're not know they're very
unhelpful no they say they did not know
what I was
doing or why and they were nervous and
they thought well you know it's just
some form of espionage wisest men do you
know it was I mean the kind of
journalism that people like myself
practice rather routinely in here I mean
a book like this a very real penetration
of a company or an institution is
relatively alien in Japan and here I was
this foreigner and I was doing it and if
I was really active the journalism what
journalists why wasn't I working for the
New York Times and they had hard time
understanding why I wasn't with a large
company what did I really want and why
so I felt that they were particularly
the beginning not very cooperative I
thought I was swimming underwater with
weights tied onto my wrists and ankles
how did you bridge the gap we just
worked very hard I mean I you know by
the time I started that book I've been a
journalist for more than 30 years and
I've done a number of other difficult
book so I think you know there's a great
deal to be said for doggedness I mean
you just keep banging your head because
I used to have a phrase when I was in
Japan I don't know if you know football
but the great ohio state teams of Woody
Hayes of them they were said three yards
and a cloud of dust me you just grind it
out I amended that to a yard and a
quarter and a cloud of our guests before
writing these books are was a reporter
for The New York Times for a very long
time ago that's 20 years ago when T
years ago years ago years was that your
first job oh no I work on a small paper
in Mississippi and then I worked for
four years in Nashville Tennessee I came
up you know class a double-a and then I
joined the major leagues in 1960 when my
batting average one over 300 won a
Pulitzer Prize in 1964 it's written nine
books total the most recent the
reckoning which we showed you earlier
the best and the brightest and the
powers be and we are now going to kick
our next call from waltham massachusetts
good morning yeah made a lot of problems
with the ottoman entry to the way that
is covered by the media in that the
media already doesn't focus on the
weight of the industry part that is
independent foreign the distinction
between Maggie bad thing and design for
product engineers who designed the
product and then come up
there were a very small minority at some
very small number of people who manage
such fun and designed products make a
sheet of paper schematics which describe
where cars made and then they handed
over to the manufacturing which is
ninety-five percent of probably of the
employees of the company of law
including sale and that those people
basically are responsible which is
simply reproducing on a consistent basis
what the design is the product made in
Brooklyn so those are two major wings in
the company which will get repetitive
division and it's a problem in that five
percent the engineering part of it that
we've got that have rectified okay thank
you very much thank you very much
walking well one thing the Japanese do
significantly better than we do is they
they design for manufacturing there is a
greater integration between those who
would design and those who would
manufacture so that the people who are
actually going to build the cars are in
the design room and vice versa so that
you do not come up with something in the
design that is terribly hard to finally
build and therefore lens to low quality
is what they do is they say here's what
we want for quality design so that we
can have high quality in the
manufacturing process and and we have
not comprehend that the our culture of
American company has for most of the
last 30 years been dominated by a
finance category people out of the
Harvard Business School to comparable
business schools who whose ideas way to
maximize profit the Japanese have made
the surge on a primacy of manufacturing
and you don't get to be high in the
Japanese company unless you have really
run a line the second thing we do is we
have our engineers who go to these
companies and far more abstract roles
when we have good engineering people
they don't they're really in a little
kind of glass and closed but they're not
down on a line the Japanese flood the
factory floor with manufacturing
engineers and they make tiny incremental
changes one of the men i like the most
in doing this book is a man named on
linux who
had been at forward in manufacturing and
then Xerox and then finally at harvester
and he was interesting because where
most people were sort of in the world of
finance he was a guy who was a business
degree had gone from finance to
manufacturing and I talked to him about
when he finally first went to Japan and
he said it was a real epiphany he went
online and he could see what they died
he said it wasn't that they made one
quantum improvement to make their
manufacturing line better than ours but
that had been a thousand increments tiny
increments of working manufacturing
engineers on that line making this
little improvement this little
improvement this lil improvement this
will improvement until one day it was as
if someone had made a quantum memories
their lines were better and the quality
was built in they've done that better
than we have and he thought that was a
novel idea what he wanted it was the
process they had made they had built
into their process and excellence of
quality by just keeping that many
manufacturing engineers right on the
line there their engineers were getting
their hands dirty Ocean City New Jersey
good morning your next up hello you're
on the air go ahead Rome or two and do
you feel in your shortly the Japanese
people that being with Japan loss
towards us that they would have in the
back of their mind that we can't beat
them militarily why can't we beat them
economically Thank You action setting is
what interesting question Japan ended
World War two we defeated not just
physically ravaged but i believe
spiritually ravaged as well it was as if
a God had failed the greater the great I
mean Japan is very nationalistic country
and they believed in themselves and the
Emperor and they're great destiny and
they got crunched when there was nothing
left and so this they were being
occupied by America Douglas MacArthur
was in effect the governor-general but
even more they wanted to look around and
see how had the victors done it what
secret do we have
and there is a period in there for about
15 to 20 years we are we are the best
teachers in the world and they are the
best students whatever we do is right
they are God's they come and photograph
every American plant we are wildly
generous we are very generous Victor's
they photograph and tape every American
lecture I mean whatever it is we have a
secret they want to know and out of that
and of course they also had a vision
that they could only be a great society
and as in Japan wants to be a great
nation by dint of a commercial thrust
that the military future was over they
tried it once they couldn't do it now in
a nuclear age with that tiny little I
with those huge cities they were
terribly vulnerable they had no military
future there for their only future was a
commercial one and they placed all of
this energy into a commercial future and
also into studying how the victor had
done it and why and they were better our
best teachers were their best teachers I
mean they were better students than we
were of our own teachers next is red
bank new jersey good morning I'm very
much concerned that the thought of the
dollar should have given our local
manufacturers there's some sort of
umbrella the move away by price
increases by the industry and the import
number doesn't seem to obtain very much
those things be around 30 set and Cara
crop it's a very good point a very good
question there's a tendency because our
companies are financially driven that
when they get them an advantage like
that to do it by price Marvin Runyon who
is a former Nita Ford man who laid
around the Nissan factory for time and
Smyrna just was wildly critical of the
American companies of trying to you know
exploit the changes in the dollar was
out and the dollar yen dollar thing
without really making the cars better
and pushing the process more he doesn't
think we can really compete and we
haven't worked hard enough to compete
there my instinct is with the Japanese
and I think it's very impressive when
they got when they were hit with the end
dollar thing when they go from 240 to
150 within a year
that's a traumatic event from and that's
not unlike 1979 1980 when the price of
oil quadruples in this country I mean
you could call it we call it oil shock
then they call this a dollar shock the
interesting thing about them is they did
not in these companies immediately
decide to do offshore production which
would be if you were from Harvard
Business School and you were given a
comparable blood no you would have come
up with let's do it and the cheapest
company was to do offshore they didn't
try and you know figure out ways to keep
what they did was the top executives
took major cuts in their salaries I mean
it took the burden on themselves
obligation at the very top of the
company the second thing they did was
they tried to make the process better
and take money out of the process they
were very process-oriented the most
extraordinary thing has happened is
they've gone through this traumatic
thing whether the N dollar has been
changed they have continued to be
competitive anything more competitive
than ever they have not gone off shore
they have now landed in this country end
up producing here and I think they come
out stronger than ever I mean while
technically our companies have been
making money in this period what's the
important thing to look at is how strong
the Japanese have come out of a very
difficult time David Halberstam our
guest for this 45 minutes this morning
as we're taking your phone calls east
and central time zone lines are let open
but we have a few lines open out early
in the West and Pacific the West End
mountain time zone and we'd invite you
to join us and you'll see that phone
number at the bottom of your screen 202
783 2727 long island your next caller go
ahead money more like how kreidler get
into the journal of you know writing
book oh well you know i was reported for
about 12 years from newspapers and i
love didn't I had good assignments New
York Times sent me to the Congo which is
now is I year Vietnam I was 25 years ago
Eastern Europe from which I was
inevitably expelled I did all that for a
long time then is a point where you
think your daily journals I want to ask
longer questions and get more
information and write something longer
you get caught up you get tired of going
to press conferences there's a
difference if you've been in a while you
become more sophisticated
more curious I see and I wanted to write
longer stories I didn't want to go to
press comes and I want I was struck by
the difference between what is called
news which is a press conference and
when I began to perceive as reality
which was something more complicated and
I thought by doing books and magazine I
could achieve where I perceived to be
reality that's what I've done with these
three books is that a critique of
today's well I think I mean I think I
understands are very good today but I
think that you know but there is a
quickness it is the first rough draft of
history and Philip grams phrase you are
there you have to get something in you
often don't get in cause and effect at
James Reston who is one of the great
editors and journalist at the Times one
set of newspapers I think quite
accurately we can cover revolution but
we don't cover evolution I'd like to be
in on this book is a book about
evolution there's no one big news story
in it is a book about the changing of
two societies and I wanted to cover that
that's why I went to book what about the
electronic media well it's all I mean
they're terribly talented people there
when you watch the coffle show at night
or you watch The Sunday morning CBS show
with the Charles Kuralt you're aware of
how good they can be but the real
problem is trying to do the world in 22
minutes i means the new york times on a
postage stamp or I mean it's you do a
complicated story and it's done in a
minute 15 seconds I think the older I
get as a journalist the more I am
interested in subtlety complexity in
little things the very nature of their
format I think works against subtle be
the more the more violent the event they
can cover it the more outrageous the
statement they're willing to cover it
subtlety incremental change they're not
very good at I mean they don't know how
to cover for example the Japanese
challenge it's a very good example I
mean they're doing a scandalous job on
what is a major American crisis and
they're doing it because they don't
because it doesn't fit to film I mean
Henry Ford the second who died a couple
days ago if he had gone over and punched
so each row home to the head of home to
in the nose they would've they would
film that that's news but the idea that
an American company and the whole
American industry is made vulnerable
a Japanese industry is powerful well
maybe you get a story you get a picture
of a bunch of it cars unloading in
California they'll do a two-minute story
but this is a this is a sea change event
I mean this is like an ice floe change
and they don't know how to cover it as
an ongoing thing and that's a very
serious problem because they're a
principal part of the circulatory system
of democracy they can't as they can't
cover it it isn't a part of the American
agenda and our varying politicians don't
have to deal with it when they run for
office it's a very serious problem have
you faced that challenge or that
frustration and going out to sell your
books to a media where I had a lot of
problems when I first book was first
published a lot of shows that had put me
on on previous books look at this book
and said oh you know it's too
complicated we only give you five
minutes and I mean Donahue who had put
me on in the past on other books never
responded I mean there were a number it
shows that I thought I would get on and
just the idea was well this is it's not
sexy enough and it's not and it's too
complicated what's upsetting I mean I
there I am getting maybe at lucky four
minutes and five minutes on American
television on an important national show
and in japan nhk their main television
show is doing a four hour documentary on
and did it that scares me Providence
Rhode Island thanks for waiting your
next step appreciative over your comment
collar I have to ask you to turn your
television set down okay thank you right
here Thank You America anyway I have to
lead to live in Hawaii five years and
reduced while I was involved japen we're
getting not altogether on my Croatia
Algerian theory they work very high or
very well disapprove but I don't
hopefully get there
some element of mind control involved
their discipline although I do respect
them and then I well the challenge in
the competition here in America and I
believe it's a healthy situation for all
all people Thank You Rhode Island can I
have a question what I think there's a
question here is the first thing is that
yes it is a healthy challenge if we are
lucky we will treat this challenge like
an alarm clock like Sputnik in 1957 it
is it is there it is a voice saying to
us that we are not doing as well as we
used to do that we're doing things wrong
that we are not who we think we are no
longer the American Century is over and
we no longer automatically set the stem
I think that's importantly on the
question of mind control I would descend
strongly from that I don't think the
Japanese practice mind control they work
hard they are very disciplined it's a
major cultural difference i think in
japan when you grow up you are taught in
school school because it's a Confucian
society and because authority is very
important you do not challenge people
who are older than you or more powerful
than you you do not challenge your
parents do not challenge you teacher you
accept Authority it's very eerie to
lecture there you go to these very
bright students and you give a lecture
and nobody says anything these I mean
there's it's sighs no sighs well maybe
you'll get a question while but I mean
there's no challenge is none of that
give and take them makes American
schools so exciting and that is because
it is drummed into them not to challenge
authority to accept it that's not mind
control but it is a different cultural
attitude it grows up I think because
there are so many people in so small
space but if anybody if everybody there
were used freedom of speech as
excessively as we did the whole fabric
of the company country would come apart
and as such they have learned to keep
things in they feel them have attitudes
but they do not as readily express them
Auburn Washington go ahead yeah
after all but a newscaster a scene where
they hadn't learn Quran files on offers
for Ibaka I'm sorry Carla I'm going to
ask you that reflection on the files on
origin yeah can you can you start your
question over again Washington go ahead
I'm afraid we have lost a call can you
can you comment it was lousy liar files
at the FBI kept on riders mr. Hoover
seemed to have been bothered by the
loyalties and patriotism of John
Steinbeck Thomas Wolfe Ernest Hemingway
many others I it was just mean seen
reflection I'm neurosis and mr. Hoover I
think not on the loyalty of the riders
who are obviously wonderful American
writers how would you feel if because of
your books or your look at of the way
American industry and Japanese industry
runs that you're reading with that well
I I'm not worried about it I've always
been really quite serious a good citizen
these book I think of the engine of
these books is self-evident love of
country maybe a different definition of
love of country then mr. Hoover might
have given but I'm not worried and I
think if you write books and go into the
public arena they're not as I do you
have to assume a certain amount of
tension and and I've never seen my FBI
file I don't particularly want to I mean
I don't have any doubt about my loyalty
but I don't doubt that at certain times
in my life when I was covering the
things that awful lot of dumb stuff went
into it and I think you know it doesn't
bother me because I'm aware of the
extraordinary freedoms we have in this
society in addition to the dumb stories
about Hemingway you have to understand
how free those riders were and how
well-received they work I've had a very
privileged life I've been treated very
well by this country that if there's
something dumb in my FB i-- Oh file so
be it i wouldn't trade this freedom for
anything des moines iowa good morning go
ahead good why you say hello to you
special I'm doing this I do have a
question but for a tour to it we have
and then I don't want to take this
seriously but I
it doesn't look like water you're
drinking poison while did you find to my
wife Marisa that is a coffee thanks
earlier I got up rather early i graduate
from testify before a congressional
committee good morning and there wasn't
time to have breakfast in my room so
this is my one glass of free c-span
coffee you if it looks like whiskey out
there all the better foot than I thought
I know I don't you swap them out down
there sake didn't mean to there's a
picture that I will we will need them
maybe we'll get together do something
about the FBI Phoenix Arizona can I help
you Phoenix Arizona your next appt yes
mr. Howard i won the facebook about
these looking for this short-term profit
yes a lot of time off there were
probably doing anything about the
manufacturing people getting into those
acting on the floor over here
all-american oh thank you can i I'm the
latter part of your question firs I
think there's been some change and we
certainly have improved quality a good
deal but we're but we're not changing
fast enough i don't think i mean the
culture those companies is still very
much financial and i think it's hard to
get good people to go into manufacturing
we haven't rewarded them well enough we
treated them really somewhat like
second-class citizens and that becomes
part of the overall problem of improving
ourselves on the earlier part of what
you said in terms of long-range
short-range that again remains a problem
American capitalism now is if anything
more volatile than ever with all these
mergers & Co varying companies trying to
swallow up others that means that a
manufacturer try of a small company that
makes widgets out in Ohio he knows what
the right thing to do is but if he does
the right thing it may not drive the
stock up fast enough because he want to
do he wants to do long range thing and
it doesn't drive a stock up he is a
patsy he's vulnerable to one of these
predators so he ends up doing the wrong
thing the thing he knows it doesn't make
better widgets it makes a lesser
widgets but it keeps them from being
swallowed up by some one of these merger
crazy predators out there so we are
vulnerable on that and the Japanese are
are exploiting that I do believe Dubuque
Iowa good morning yes the single the
Templars you know um we might have
something that happened to me a couple
years ago when i was in kansas city
fella draw in the filling station that
was filling up as Carla gas and he says
I just got laid off at four I don't know
what the hell I'm going to do you know
he says and I shouldn't your fault he's
driving a brand-new Toyota I mean you
know what what is your comment on it is
the American people's fault that the
Japanese are taking over the country
thank you to ground I don't notice the
American people's fault but I think if
the Japanese as they did in the 70s made
cars of higher quality responded more
and better to customer complained gave
better service cars were better
rust-proof or whatever and Americans got
frustrated with the kinds of cars they
were getting particularly in the
beginning in the low end of the market
it's a natural thing to buy the Japanese
car you're probably watching this show
on a Japanese television set whether
something comfortable javed I mean
American companies were really still in
a kind of monopoly era they had been so
prosperous for so long they didn't
believe that anybody could challenge
them they have sort of a big three and
they just could cut the pie up as they
wanted in the quah they paid lip service
to quality and lip service to
technological innovation but what they
were really doing was trying to ship as
many cars as they could no matter what
the quality was and in that atmosphere
the Japanese with their priority of
quality did very well and I wouldn't
blame the American people I would blame
the the company's the union's everybody
who is a part of that era any blame that
you lay to Congress well I think there's
enough for everybody in the society me
I'm the media the congressman and they
were all part of it if you have a whole
societal ever
which we end up being somewhat
complacent and not seeing the world is
changing when the world is changing then
is enough to go around for everybody
Albuquerque good morning go ahead yeah
too don't forget worker security
programs in Japanese factories for a
long time we heard make you about
japanese-style work brewer's art of
hired for life Oh unable to do a
particular job is be trained in the
factory and continue to be an employee
or reasonably and if a number of
disturbing reports about that maybe to
the certain core group within the
various factories don't go for a great
many of their of the parking of
different times the outsourced from to
subcontractors that Darwin trouble well
I can't get too rough your day is hard
immediately and very much the same to
everything happens in slow time to stand
true okay I don't know but I don't think
that's true Smyrna by the way up to my
knowledge it's not I am I what is true
is at the lifetime guaranteed job in
Japan is under more challenge now as
that as their society comes under town
from Korea and others they are they are
and as the auto industry has become a
mature industry they are having a lot of
problems and what has also been always
been true is a while Toyota and Nissan
may give a lifetime job guarantee the
supplier companies in fact give much
less in the way of benefits and there
are fewer protections there so that the
caller is right that that in this
country that the supplier companies were
given were in fact paying a good deal
more and giving more protections and was
happening in Japan for those of us
remain I know smyrna is the plant the
news on man in Tennessee rosemary
concord decal georgia good morning go
ahead
I can trust and now I can't thank you ah
dude just don't they know the name of
the three people on that dimension
Leroy's down frank-walter artane but I
wish Frank waldrop a journalist for The
Washington star can you help us out why
are you asking ah David come on my
favorite these people bit off the road
booth and I think I knew Frank Walter
but I don't know some of the others
ranked Walder with Washington store I
think they're worth money Washington
that way okay my day is thank you very
much for calling wanted to ask you you
had mentioned before about a caller had
mentioned that work for security the
newspapers out today say that for
brokers have approved 321 a new contract
that gives them a lot more security
according to these paper reports what do
you think about that well I think for
new aw in the last contract negotiations
on both sides were created they are
aware increasingly that they live in a
different world and what the Union did
was it gave up i think immediacy of rate
increases which they usually go for to
try and protect jobs because they're
feeling very vulnerable and Ford I think
accommodated to some degree to that so
it was I think a change it was a
different kind of negotiation that you
might have had 10 years ago though it's
a reflection of change circumstance in
that boise idaho go ahead 100 we are
having california choice i want to ask
you about front page story the Robert
Pera rights in the New York Times this
morning which he said that economic
expansion in the US continues today
begins the 59th consecutive month of
economic expansion in this country
according to his story the third longest
period of economic expansion since
records began how do you take a look at
that and then try a very wary of the
story like that which I'm having come
over you're very early
having time to read and you guys start
early right the question is what kind of
mean what kind of jobs are those I mean
you're talking now about a nation whose
debt grows all the time there were
detonation in the same five-year period
that he's talking about we were talking
about in those five years a constant
growth in the inbounds the trade
imbalance with Japan if you had a chart
for those five years and we could put it
up I be you and I would be appalled how
the trade deficit has mounted with
Eastasia we are talking about an
extraordinary five year period of
out-migration of what I would call good
blue collar jobs industrial jobs we're
losing them they're either going to high
technology or they're being outsourced
into Asia or Latin America so what that
figure means i don't know but i suspect
it means not terribly good jobs in the
low end of the service industry i don't
think we're a particularly productive
dynamic country now I think we're
vulnerable i think and i see that story
you quoted to me and i am weary of it
because i think the american core
economy is soft and we are replacing
vital dynamic jobs with jobs that in
fact don't offer a very great dignity
and if you adjusted them for inflation
mine fact be like jobs that predated
franklin roosevelt the new deal were not
particularly good ones there's a story
like this and the front page of
newspapers across the country make the
people make American people a little bit
more difficult to to believe something
like I doubt seriously because I think
most people feel very nervous about the
country in where it's going they feel
their own buying power a diminish it's
not as strong as it was say 10 years ago
they at once are buying a Japanese
product and aware that it might be
costing them possibly their own job I
think they're very uneasy with the
direction of the country I think if
there's a core thing under the surface
of this country it's a real fear about
where the country's going economically
and the genuine fear for the first time
in my lifetime that your children will
live as well
and I believe that again I think if you
were tapping I'm not a pollster but if
you were tapping into something the
great uncertainty in the minds and
psyche of the American people it would
be about that question but my children
live as well as as I do and in fact for
most of my life comment has been an
assumption a part of the glue to the
American dream that our children will
live better than we do I've tried to
take my much call Jacksonville Florida
you're up yes talk about the Japanese
people for our effects and some people I
make Mary Marsh number one hours of
priorities under seven also what
Japanese a marine every starting all the
way up to my fellow operation now first
contact with a Japanese the 1946 in the
security 40 acoust custom and at that
time I had nobody was more bitter than I
and I didn't really learn the Japanese
1953 I went back over there for a couple
years the degrees that people refer to
be behind that met the people and all of
a sudden I found out one thing about
them they were like our forefathers they
work hard they didn't care what kind
they give you service I was arrogant in
58 in 1958 they were still the same
people they weren't tired they give you
service they looked at you and all I
could hear from the people around the
Americans but because they count out and
everything else because they were polite
look at those suffering look what they
do for you there we go okay floor i'm
going to have to let you go there
because we're out of time I think it's
very important that harder this thing I
mean they're a lot when you're trying to
figure out what's going on in America
and what's going on in Japan why the
Japanese are being successful one of the
reasons is right now for the last 20 30
years the Japanese have in fact worked
harder and worked better more carefully
it's Benny better team that's been less
waste as far back is 1951 Averill Herman
was sent out during the korean war on a
mission by harry truman to talk to a
douglas macarthur and in the midst of
their conversation one point macarthur
turned una said pay attention to the
Japanese they Revere and sanctify work
whereas in my own
country meeting America people now are
preoccupied with leisure I think there
has been an element of that I think the
Japanese really are more like our
grandparents and I think we've got to
get back to some fundamentals and waste
less time and I think that I mean there
are a lot of reasons why Japanese have
been doing better than us but one of the
reasons is they work harder there John
Calvin would be more comfortable in
Japan today than in America to David
Halberstam is the author of this book
The Reckoning and also not at eight
other books rather what are you working
on that what I'm doing book on the 50s
and I'm doing a book on a season in
baseball the Yankees and the Red Sox in
1949 kind of fun for me thank you for
joining us with money